so anthony the stock market dove a year
ago
and in a matter of a couple months it
was back
and the people that dove out of the
stock market when they
because they were at home being
quarantined one year ago right now
are upset were freaked out yep and they
thought oh
this pandemic is truly the end of the
world
the stock market i mean you know they
they were really there was terror there
was a lot of
real fear yes and you and i are doing a
lot of media then
all the ramsey personalities were doing
streaming events out of here the
message of hope went out we did all
these different things trying to get
people to calm down and just go
back up pan out have a long-term
perspective
this too shall pass and it passed from
an investment perspective
faster than the actual virus passed
absolutely
i mean i i thought the investments might
take a year to come back
and the kova to be gone in a month yeah
and it's quite the opposite
it's taken a year to get the covet stuff
out of most people's systems it's not
out of everybody's system yet
right and uh uh but the investments have
been back a long time
yeah they came back quick and if you
have all the data tells us that if you
have a professional in your corner that
talk you off the ledge keep you from
panicking
that you have a higher probability of
making money it's not that their
investments necessarily are better than
you would have picked on your own
it's that you don't jump off a cliff
absolutely you know my investor dave
when i when i called my
uh smart investor he said hey and this
is something i've heard you say but he
said do not forget
on paper yes it's going to go down but
when you take it out that's permanent
it will go back up it has to go back up
and he said
i he said it was probably like around
last september
he suspected it will be back up within
eight months and and dave it went right
back up and the numbers were
very well and i remember all of us
begging people
do not touch your investments do not
touch your 401k
even though the government was giving
you a way out do not touch your roth
iras do not touch none of the stuff
and now i have friends who have called
me and said i messed up
yeah oh yeah yeah they they wouldn't
listen to you whitney
listen to me wouldn't you know it's like
and that's
your your smart mr pro was correct when
it goes down and you sell
you actually have locked in we call it
you locked in your losses
you guaranteed that you're going to lose
money yes sir because you just did
yeah you know and so versus i remember
uh
somebody said to warren buffett one time
his you know the price of the stock
portfolio that he had went down
uh several billion dollars uh in a you
know in one of these downturns
and they said you know mr buffett you
just lost several billion dollars and he
said
no i didn't hold the old paper
i haven't i haven't sold it yeah when i
sell it that's when i've lost it yep
when it comes back up and did i gain it
you know no not till i you know you did
you make several billion no not till i
sell it right
you know so it's just you know you and
me anything until you
actually put the money in your pocket or
put the loss in your pocket and lock it
in
yeah and so you know but the the data
tells us
that just like having a personal trainer
gives you a better chance of winning
just like having a coach inside ramsey
plus gives you a better chance of
finishing your dead snowball yeah
a smartvestor pro in your corner gives
you a better chance of staying in the
investment which is
actually the statistical key the secret
sauce is not figuring out the perfect
investment the perfect
the secret sauce is keep investing and
never stop never stop yep
and also one of the secret sauce david i
think which i love hearing you
you know even at your level of status
you still have a smart investor pro that
just educates you on certain things when
you meet with them on a yearly basis
and i was like man i'm constantly
learning
even when i was even a little fearful
myself last year dave i said all right
cool i'm gonna trust dave i'm gonna
trust you all
i'm not gonna touch this thing and dave
i'm i'm trying to tell you even a small
fear that did hit me for
a quick second i ain't gonna say sure
sure no it does i mean it hit
you're not human if you're not facing
some big blow up thing like a pandemic
and you don't go oh my god what's
happening here yeah i mean in 2008 i
remember distinctly
sitting i had done three shows on fox
yeah in new york
and the the stock market is going off a
cliff i mean it went from thirteen
thousand sixty five hundred
i mean it's going off a cliff and i
remember sitting in the steak house
there right next to fox
sharon and i went over there for lunch
after i just finished neil cavuto and
i've been in there with neal neal smart
as a way up
and he's like aren't you scared i'm no
i'm not scared no i'm not scared i kept
saying no i'm not scared
and then i'm sitting there in that in in
new york city in this steakhouse and i'm
watching these big red letters go across
the side of the fox building
watching the stock market drop minute by
minute by minute
it's dropping and i know this stuff i
teach this stuff right
i'm going every people that are smarter
than me are scared maybe i should be
scared
and i said sharon am i dumb we're not
being scared and she said no we actually
know what we're doing we've been through
these kinds of things before
and we're people of faith we don't place
all of our uh
all of our happiness based on the size
of our stinking bank account exactly
anyway and we've been broke before and
we didn't lose our minds then we'd be
broke again and we'll
be all right but we're not going to be
broke it's going to be okay yeah
yeah i mean and that's how i felt too
dave honestly i was oh okay get over
this fear and
keep on moving and i'm so grateful that
i didn't do it great so grateful my
family didn't do it but i have to be
honest
i was sad and hurt that my friends
didn't listen
yeah well you gotta have somebody in
your corner to talk you off the ledge
that's what it comes down